[Music]
and uh step forgive me for what I'm
about to
[Music]
do he sh the fool what
he
Ste oh my God my favorite All-Star
introduction number four Andre Drummond
no not Andre have better odds at hitting
the loty than completing this
pass
oh
man we're in Vegas we're in Vegas okay
better
30 number three Jordan pool okay sh in
the pool needs to go back to
school what are you doing what are you
doing
[Music]
oh
goodness jump
[Music]
sh get out of
here number two Draymond Green Draymond
with the worst acting job did Stephen A
on General Hospital
brick worse than brick
[Applause]
sh a on General hosal oh my Lord
[Music]
that's how I look Steve
sure number
one here we goch was Blasphemous oh no
no come on man 40 ft like a
soft like a
soft see that strike come
on that that was one of the classic sha
and a fools of all time great sha I
apologize my good friend all I'm going
to do is remind y'all this I got a twoh
hour weekday show five days a week I'm
going to get y'all I'm going to get
y'all for this I don't know how but I'm
going to get
y'all